good afternoon hello everyone my name is
Dean tamama bethl I am assistant dean of
Y college and director of the
afroamerican cultural center more
affectionately known as the house AKA
this big beautiful building you're
sitting in right now um so welcome home
uh before we begin I would like to do
the land
acknowledgement um so Yale University
acknowledges that indigenous people and
Nations including the Mohan the
mashentuck Pat the eastn Pat the shatak
the Golden Hill Paget the Niantic and
the quinc and other alaka speaking
peoples have stewarded through
generations the land and water ways of
what is now the state of Connecticut and
where our University sits we honor and
respect the enduring relationship that
exists between these peoples and nations
in this
land I would like to briefly tell you a
bit about the house before for our event
begins today so the afroamerican
cultural center was founded in
1969 by three y undergraduates Don Alby
armet Robinson and Glendy they worked
for two years with local New Haven
activists and some professors on campus
to petition the university Forest base
for black students to call home while
they were here at Yale luckily smartly
uh the Yale Corporation approved their
petition and we were granted our Center
in 1969 we moved into this building in
19 71 and we've been here ever since the
house is home to over 50 student
organizations both undergraduates and
graduate and professional students who
are able to use our space free of charge
have their events here get resources and
get guidance from our professional staff
which as of right now is just me um
along with the 54 year Rich history of
the house the house continues to be
mostly run by students so we have over
50 student staff here and myself um with
over 2,000 black undergrads and GMP
students here at Yale um so it's very
exciting especially as an Alum of Yale
College from the class of 2011 to be a
to be here to Steward El Le through this
space and this experience um I welcome
all of you and I encourage you to
explore the space once this event is
over it is the first Cultural Center on
y's campus the first black cultural
center of the IV league and one of the
first black cultural centers in the
country um it is also the largest and in
my opinion the best building on this
campus the best Cultural Center on this
campus so please be sure to explore our
building we have a library Art Gallery
meeting spaces and things and we are
very excited to have all of you here for
this wonderful and very purposeful And
Timely event today um and with that I
will pass you off to Dean
[Music]
Momi
Sor thank you very much and thank you
very much for allowing us to host our
event here in this beautiful beautiful
house I I I really feel honored to be in
this place uh today and I would like to
um just welcome all of you good
afternoon and thank you very much for
joining us today uh we are
all sorry we're all so pleased to
welcome award-winning filmmaker Tanya
Louis Lee who is here with us in this
beautiful house for this special
Centennial
conversation as you know that we are
celebrating our Centennial this year and
this is a part of a series of wonderful
events that we are going to hold
throughout this
year I know we all look forward to
hearing about her documentary film After
Shock I hope that you have all watch it
watched it and her important work in the
areas of maternal mortality and social
justice these are two areas that we care
so much about in the Yale School of
Nursing and we can't wait to hear the
conversation here and
and to uh learn more about both areas
and to see what could we do as an
institution to be able to uh promote uh
uh you know social justice and Health
Equity uh and health Justice across the
United States uh I would also uh uh
would like to welcome four of our
precious Yale School of Nursing faculty
who are going to participate in the this
conversation today um Midwife and
student Equity
coordinator uh Heather
rolds uh nurse mfy specialty
co-directors John kellic and
Michelle teler and also last but not
least our former interim Dean
of Yale School of Nursing Holly Powell
Kennedy and Helen warney professor of
[Applause]
midy I also would like to use this
opportunity to acknowledge and thank the
many people whose efforts made um
today's event possible including T's
team H Michelle C Mike rean I think that
some of you are here so if you are here
just Wing so that we can see you uh
Taylor
teston Peter uh
platica Lauren
Langford and Marsha Thomas here thank
you very much and now it's my real
pleasure to welcome heer
Ral to to the podium for
[Applause]
introducing oh my gosh it's so good to
be back in this place I was here as a
student back in the 70s so for me this
is like a
homecoming um I just want to say that
this incredible lady Tanya Lewis Lee is
a producer film director writer
entrepreneur and Women's Health Advocate
who for over 20 years has been
delivering
meaningful content that resonates with
marginalized communities as a television
producer Lee served as executive
producer on the Netflix series she's got
to have it it was a movie before and
then became a series she produced her
first limited series Miracles boys at
Nickelodeon based on the Jacqueline
Woodson novel of the same name which
remains a classic
today um as a film producer Lee produced
the adaptation of the Walter Dean Meers
novel monster which premiered in
competition at at the 2018 Sundance Film
Festival and is streaming on
Netflix most recently Lee co-directed
and co-produced the Emmy nominated puddy
awardwinning Aftershock which we're
going to be celebrating today which
examines the US maternal mortality
crisis the documentary premiered at the
2020 Sundance Film Festival and won the
special jury award for impact for change
it was acquired by Onyx and ABC News to
release on Hulu in 20 July of this year
of last year as a writer Tanya Penn the
script for the Watsons go to Birmingham
an adaptation of the Christopher Paul
Curtis novel that she also produced for
the Hallmark Channel she is the author
of three children's books including the
classic please baby please as well as
the adult novel Gotham
Diaries she has done a lot we're almost
there cuz we want to hear from her in
2007 Tanya became the spokesperson for
the US Department of Health and Human
Services office of minority Health
infant mortality awareness campaign a
healthy baby begins with you which
ignited her lifelong passion for
advocating for Better Health outcomes
for all women in the United States
especially women of
color through the campaign Tanya
produced the film crisis in the crib
saving our ation babies because it's not
just m maternal mortality but infant
mortality too which is unfortunately on
the
rise this work LED Tanya to embark on
her journey as an entrepreneur to create
Mida Organics which is an organic
vitamin supplement brand to continue the
conversation with women about accessing
healthy outcomes and provide them with a
high quality resource to Aid their
well-being and overall Vitality she is a
member of the writer Guild of America
and a member of The Producers Guild of
America serving as co-chair of the one
guide committee and on the producers
Council Board of delegates she's also a
member of the Board of Trustees of the
March of Dimes where I'm also on their
advisory Council the nurses advisory
Council and a director emeritus of the
Board of Trustees of the NAACP legal
defense and educational
Fund in 2022 Indie wire featured Tanya
and their 22 Rising female filmmakers to
watch she is the mother of two adult
children and lives in New York with her
husband Ley welcome it's a pleasure
to have you
[Applause]
here my daughter's story is loud
colorful and Artful
it's she was awake aware and active baby
and yet she still
died after she gave birth Shani was
complaining that she had really sharp
chest pains the ambulance came I'm
telling them the symptoms is she on
drugs next set of people come in is she
on drugs she kept asking her mother if
she on any drugs I'm like do y'all talk
we waited solid 12
hours she's
gone black women are four times more
likely to die than their white
counterparts with the same symptoms why
is that this is a growing epidemic in
our community hundreds and thousands of
men are going through this same
[Music]
situation I've never lived in this house
without her you just got to keep pushing
forward I can't let Amber be another
statistic if these numbers were flips
around and white women were dying at the
rate the black woman is dying it would
be a national crisis we fight against
maternal morbility event by event in
order to create change we could turn our
pain into power and make something of
this Jamani
Gibson we hear you we see you I planned
on spending a lifetime with Amber I
wanted to get for my life this way I'm
still going
to the revolution will be tweeted in
Instagram Facebook this fight is not
over when black mothers die there's a
ripple
effect we call this
[Music]
Aftershock hi everybody thank you for
being here um first thank you so much to
all of you all who uh brought me here I
am truly honored and humbled to be here
to talk to you today about after shot
talk and to be in conversation with
these amazing women uh here um I want to
tell you a little bit about how I got
here before we uh start the conversation
and why uh I've been so passionate uh
about the work of maternal health and
and equalizing the maternal Health Care
here I think it's kind of obvious but I
will still talk about it um you know uh
one of the one of the things you didn't
mention in that uh bio is that I'm
lawyer by trade uh when I um graduated
from college as a young person um I
actually really wanted to be in the Arts
um I was someone who had studied a lot
of literature I went to Sarah Lawrence
College a very creative Place uh I did a
lot of writing and um but I didn't know
anyone who had a career as a creative uh
my parents were very corporate minded
and they didn't either and when I said I
wanted to go into television they were
like are you you
crazy you need to get a job so you can
make some money um uh and so I went to
law school thinking I would at one point
thinking I would be a civil rights
lawyer but then again my father was like
that's not what I meant when I sent you
to law school I want you to make some
money uh so I ended up being a corporate
lawyer although I did clerk at the NAACP
legal defense fund um and I think my my
passion I was just talking to someone
about this the other day for civil
rights and social Justice uh when I was
8 years old uh in the middle of third
grade we moved from Montclair New Jersey
to Milwaukee
Wisconsin uh and it was very uh it was a
traumatic move for me in a way my
father's company move so we moved um and
back in in that day my parents were like
yeah when Dad's going we all go uh which
is great in some ways um but moving to
Milwaukee the suburbs of Milwaukee
Wisconsin I was like the second black
student in that school
and it was a very racist place and I was
an eight-year-old child uh being bullied
by the kids not protected by the
teachers there uh and felt very alone
and at the end of the year that year my
parents transferred me to to another
school but I bring that up because what
I think I'm trying to do in the work
that I'm doing is fight for that little
eight-year-old
girl uh I think uh my work is about
trying to make the world a better place
so that other young people don't have to
go through that at the same time I
remember very clearly watching the
documentary series eyes on the prize I
these these these things Collide to me
in my mind as an adult now right eyes on
the prize was eye openening for me there
were these amazing civil rights Warriors
out there fighting that fight for all of
us to have rights I mean young people
stand standing up against dogs and water
hoses and and I think that really got
into my spirit and my soul and so you
know while I was looking to make my way
in life in some way using the things I
was an early reader I love stories I
loved watching movies I love watching TV
and ultimately somehow I wanted to bring
it all together and um you know it's
funny all of my friends were always AR
artists and then I happened to marry a
super creative amazing
artist uh who was making it work for
himself right and when we got married um
you know I talked to spike about the
fact that I really had these creative
ideas and he was like if that's what you
want to do then you should go do that
and really supported me in doing that
and uh I started by writing you know we
were I was newly married I gave up my
job uh and I'd get up in the morning and
I'd write for hours
and that resulted in ultimately my first
children's book please baby please uh
and because of please baby please and
then please puppy please the US
Department of Health and Human Services
reached out to me and asked me to be a
spokesperson for the infant mortality aw
awareness raising campaign a healthy
baby begins with you and with that
campaign I had the absolute I mean
blessed experience to travel this
country all over this country I was in
urban areas I was in rural areas um
north south east
west and got a chance to meet people uh
where they were the community uh people
who were working in community to try to
improve improve outcomes and I I got a
major education I mean at the time I
don't even think I at first knew what
infant mortal that what infant mortality
was that the US had issue that black
babies were dying at higher rates than
white babies that it didn't matter your
socioeconomic status in this country as
a black person you still had a higher
chance of losing your child before its
first
birthday and uh finding myself in
immerse in this world of ultimately
women's health because of course when we
talk about an infant we're talking about
a woman's health um I would inevitably
hear stories not only of infant death
but of mothers dying from childbirth
complications um and so as Heather
mentioned I did a film called crisis in
the crib then for the office of minority
health and I went on and continued to do
other work continue to travel with a
campaign because I think once your eyes
are opened in this way once you have the
opportunity to really get out in
community and engage with people it just
becomes a part of you it certainly did
for me I mean I I I love going into
community and talking to all kinds of
people I mean it just FS it fills me and
I feel like I take them with me and I
can share them in in other
ways um but then you know in terms of
Aftershock uh in I I think it was
2018 Linda Linda
villosa wrote uh a huge article for the
New York Times about the US maternal
mortality crisis and I I think
propublica did an article and people
were starting to talk about what was
happening in our country around maternal
health and I thought to myself I better
hurry up and make a documentary about
this because I want to give my my point
of view on it before somebody else does
because I'm going to be really mad as
somebody else does and they don't do it
right so um you know I I started
thinking about it and it's and it's a
huge issue and I I say that I joke and
say I'd be mad if someone didn't do it
right but the fact of the matter is and
I know there are other people working on
documentaries other documentaries have
come out on the issue and I think it's
really important that people put their
voice to the issue the way they see it
uh and for me it was really important to
work with somebody to find a partner
because what way there's so many
different ways in that you can go about
U making this film and so my producing
directing partner Paula and iselt and I
met at a Women's
Conference um someone introduced us they
mentioned that she had was beginning to
develop a documentary film on the issue
I was beginning to develop a documentary
film on the issue we did not know each
other uh she's a Jewish woman who lives
in New Jersey I am who I am uh we met
one day we had coffee another day and
the next thing you know we were off
making this film and the reason why we
were off to make this film together is
that we both had a shared Vision about
how this film from our perspective
needed to be told and that was centering
the women and centering the families in
a way so that first and foremost you
humanize the issue because we often hear
so much about the
statistics and it's just numbers and so
we really wanted people to feel um as
hard as it is to
feel what it means to lose a mother um
from childbirth
complications uh so that that we both
knew and at the same time we knew it was
really important to get the information
in about why this was happening uh we
wanted to talk to experts in the field
but we didn't want it to be a film with
just people talking at you we wanted you
to go on a
journey uh and so the way we began um
Shaunie shamani Gibson died in um
October 2019 I want to say Paul and I
met must have met November 2019
shamani died in
October in December her family her
mother put out a call to action uh they
were having an event a celebration of
shani's life they put it on Instagram
and invited the community uh Shaman's
partner Omari uh wanted to have a
convening of men to talk about what it
means as a man as a partner to lose
someone from from child birth
complications Paula saw this on
Instagram because she's like an
Instagram
ninja I am not um and she called shaie
and shaie answered her phone and said
hey you know we'd really like to come
and film what you guys are doing and
miraculously and and shaie speaks to
this often like she really goes by what
she feels in the spirit uh and shaie is
an amazing woman herself someone who has
been in the birth Justice reproductive
Justice work as she says in the film she
knew she knows what these issues are she
speaks to them often and yet this still
happened to her daughter uh and so I
think being that social justice Warrior
that she is she said okay well I'm going
to stand up and let the world see sort
of like uh Bruce who who was also in the
film his partner Amber Rose Isaac passed
away Bruce often says that the reason
why he decided to participate in the
film it's like he thinks about M till
when emit till was brutally murdered M
decided to open up the casket have an
open casket to show his mutilated body
so everyone could see what happened to
her son and so for Bruce opening up
himself to us as filmmakers to to all of
us to see his story as like opening up
the caskets we can see what he went
through so maybe we learn something um
and so you know Shaunie was really the
beginning Amari says that at first he
was like there's no way he was going to
do this film you know he was two months
into his grief and Shaunie too I mean
very early in their grief um but they
let us they let us come in and they let
us go through the process with them uh
after so Omari had the first men Circle
there were some other fathers who had
lost
there um so then
Amber Rose Isaac died in April of
2020 Omari hears because this is now
they're on a network right so so these
men now or these families they hear of
someone else someone died Omari reaches
out to Bruce um they develop a
relationship and because um Amari and
Bruce have this relationship Amari
explains to Bruce we're making this film
and Bruce says okay I'm going to go get
on but I will tell you before that Bruce
after I want to say so if Amber died in
April I want to say it was maybe even
two weeks after Amber died Bruce had a
press conference which we actually
filmed before we knew Bruce because we
we had heard again on social media that
he was going to have this press
conference so we brought out a camera to
capture him um doing his press
conference and thereafter we met him and
continued on the journey with
them um and I I'll say you know I make
this film
um because like I said before it seems
obvious to
me uh infants
mothers you know that is the Bedrock the
health of of women the health of infants
is the health of a Nation that's how you
mark the health of a nation and we are
not doing well at all and we should be
doing better um and so I made this film
because I want to make an impact I mean
when you hear my bio like I'm trying to
make an impact I'm trying to humanize
one the black experience because I know
as a young black child what it's like to
be dehumanized so we want to humanize
our experience for ourselves and for all
of us so we understand who we are um and
so that we can and we can come together
and I also have to say like my
partnership with Paula in making this
film I mentioned she and I are very
different we have very different points
of view and it can be very difficult to
have hard conversations about things she
doesn't understand my life experience I
don't understand her life experience
that can create conflict but I think
it's really important that we dig down
and have those
conversations I think when we are made
to feel most uncomfortable sometimes the
places where we grow the most and so as
we made this very difficult complicated
film you know we also learned and grew
from each other and um it's really my
hope that Aftershock is able to and
that's why it's so amazing to be here
with you all today um because I think
you know as as people go on in their
lives and their careers I'm hoping that
Aftershock stays in someone's brain a
little bit and especially healthc care
providers uh to think about um how you
are treating someone uh and and how uh
you can can have a real impact we all
have an impact I mean and I believe we
all have a a role to play in in making
this crisis better uh and for me it's by
storytelling um and by standing up and
by giving voice to what I can give voice
to and I'm humbled by the ability to do
that um and for you it may be something
something different um but but that's
why I'm here that's what motivates me to
make uh Aftershock and to do the other
kind of work that I'm I'm working on um
I will always be advocating for Women
and Infants Health it is of the most
important thing we can do when I saw
just this morning or yesterday the fact
that our infant mortality rate is going
up it's like WT F how can this be how
are we not as a nation putting all of
our resources to our people I just I I I
it it just because we are supposed to be
the beacon for the world and yet and yet
we have these abysmal rates it's it's
and and and it's solvable it's not like
we we can't fix it we can if we choose
to so I will continue to be fighting and
um thank you and I look forward to our
[Applause]
conversation
see the young leading the old thank
you yeah thank you so much those words
of wisdom and how we can move to Beyond
just feeling to doing and and making an
impact it's so important you know I look
at the health care system in the United
States and the structural racism that
exists is so pervasive and so
destructive to particularly to
marginalized communities with black
mothers and Indigenous women having the
worst outcomes in terms of not only
infant mortality but also maternal
mortality and I wonder you know if we
need to start looking at the health
profession
schools as where we need to put our
energies because these systems are so
entrenched you know whether or not
they're going to change quickly enough
to make the dramatic changes that we
need to see in the lives of these
families whether or not we need to start
putting some of our energies into
transforming and educating people in the
health profession schools in a way that
they become more appropriate less you
know um influenced by racial you know
beliefs or whatever so that we can
ultimately change those structures to
better accommodate and care for women
particularly those who are
marginalized so I guess my question is
should we then be putting a lot more
emphasis or focus on those health
profession schools not only in creating
a diverse body of of providers but also
educating all of the providers so that
they can make changes within the systems
yeah absolutely I think I think first of
all uh building the pipeline I think we
were you know somehow I don't know if
that was you guys um but I think first
of all I mean and that's down the line
but building a pipeline of Health Care
Providers uh looking at young people
from I mean like going really young like
getting them interested and excited
about the sciences and healthc care and
and and health care and Community um and
and helping them find connectivity ways
and I know places like Robert Wood
Johnson are are doing things like that
but I think we need more and more of
that reaching to um reaching out to our
our black and brown um uh youngsters to
get them involved in healthcare
providing for those that are already
there um they're absolutely I mean it's
just amazing even some of the the way
people are taught recently um uh someone
showed me a campaign called illustrate
change I don't know if you all are
familiar with this with just to show
images in textbooks of medical textbooks
of people who are brown
like it's 2023 and you mean to tell me
that in textbooks we're really still
just seeing mostly just white people and
things show up differently on brown skin
so just integrating the way just
naturally things flow through so it's
not so obscure or odd um I also think it
seems to me that even the way Med the
medical profession teaches um it's hard
on doctors right you're dehumanized
yourself uh and so you're rushed through
you got to hurry up you got to do you
can't eat you got to grind uh and I
think often that kind of dehumanization
if you will of the health care providers
ends up trickling down often to the
patient as well so is there a more
humane way about going about the
teaching now I know it's a stressful job
don't get me wrong but I just think that
there's got to be a way that people and
I mean this is the hardest work though
right I mean how do you teach
empathy I mean that's a hard thing to
teach people again come with life
experience before they get there you
know we live in a white supremist
society that is driving you in a certain
place it's it's has to be active work to
to change that mindset uh so I do think
institutions really need to be thinking
about that and I I'll end this by saying
as we all know when you solve the
problem for the most M marginalized the
most vulnerable you solve it for
everyone and by the way nobody's doing
all that well compared to other
industrialized
nations I have a question or two but
before I ask that I I want to say thank
you to you um for also allowing the
school of of Nursing and our nursing and
Midwifery students and faculty and staff
to kind of be in your glow for a while
and um and uh have you here amongst us
so is very special for us um along the
lines of
um the educational pipeline three of us
here are actually on the admissions
committee this year and um I would like
your opinion of the recent Supreme Court
decision that enforces race blind
admissions um and how you think that
will impact um our ability to diversify
e ethnically culturally racially our
Workforce which has been a priority of
the Yale School of Nursing historically
um and it's very present for us at this
moment as we're beginning to receive um
applications yeah I can I can only
imagine what it's like uh working in
these institutions with that decision
coming down
um first I feel
like the numbers weren't that high to
begin with let's start with that right
let's let's just be clear I just want to
say that it's not like you know there
were lots of black and brown people
coming through and so you know this
decision is stopping the flood of
unqualified black and brown people that
is just BS we know that right so um I
think I think it's interesting I wonder
how I know you all are under a lot of
pressure um and I wonder what the impact
will be um I have to say I call out
Edward Bloom by name because this is a
campaign directed by a person that is
not who is who has other people behind
him don't get me wrong he's not the only
one but there is a person who is on a
mission to take things away from black
and brown people including women and I
have to you mention the affirmative
action I'm going to get back to school
but he also came after the Fearless fund
if you don't know which is a venture
fund that supports black and brown women
looking to have their own economic
independence they only give
$20,000 to per entrepreneur and he wants
to stop that when we get like such a
tiny amount of funding from Venture
funds so I say that to say there is an
assault coming to stop and it's amazing
because the numbers are so small so what
are you what are they so afraid of um
you know in some ways I look and I say
well gosh black and brown women must be
doing something right you know we we
must be a force to be reckoned with and
I guess Trump would tell you that too
when he looks at who's Prosecuting him
but sorry that's an
aside um you know I think you all have a
challenge and I think I think your
challenge again goes to what happens
before the admissions process and I
don't know what you can do about that
but I feel like there needs again to you
need to start way earlier getting young
people ready to get here get excited and
be here and be able to be admitted in
the right way um and I think I think
that's what's that's what's going to
have to change I also think you're going
to have to be
crafty you know um you know I don't I
can't remember what it's like applying
to grad school it was so long ago that I
did um but really like looking at who
the whole person is uh and understanding
who that person is and really making
sure they're supported once they get
here I mean I think that's the other
thing I mean you know it's one thing to
be admitted it's another thing to make
it through and people really need a lot
of support uh when they are here so um I
think you're up against a lot of
challenges right now it's a it's a it's
a tough time and for those of you you
who are here I mean you're in a
battle I mean you're on the front I mean
this is Frontline battle stuff um put
your armor on because they're going to
keep coming they might you know you got
here you're getting through it I'm sure
there there are complications and
difficulties while you're here and
they're going to be when you get out of
here wherever you go after that so put
your armor on get your battle gear make
sure you've got the people around you
that support you and understand what
you're doing um because it doesn't get
easier
uh and don't give up because you're
doing something right because that's why
they're trying to stop
us would it be okay if I just ask our
nursing and Midwifery students to stand
up that are
here would you guys be up to would you
[Applause]
be I'm excited to see them um I just I
just want to really thank you for for
doing what you're doing it's really
important work uh so so thank thank you
and thank you for being
here my second question is um if you can
talk about this what's your next Equity
related project that you're thinking
about working on where are you going
from
here very different kind of project um
I've done some heavy stuff uh I did uh
as you heard I I made the film monster
before this which is about a 17-year-old
kid who's un incarcerated uh for his
partner robbery and then did
Aftershock so what I'm working on right
now is and I don't know if it'll
actually see the light of day but I'm
working on it it's a script um that is a
feature
film uh that's
horror uh that deals a little bit with
um well I'll just tell you it's you know
the the land in Martha's Vineyard I
think a lot of people think of Martha's
Vineyard these days as one thing uh what
it is um it's funny if you Google
Martha's Vineyard it begins uh the story
of Martha's Vineyard begins with white
people showing up on the shores like
there were not indigenous people there
who have been there since 20,000 BC so
I'm having a little bit of fun uh trying
to and I you know of course I'm making
it so complicated for myself my son is
like I don't know why you're working so
hard look at all that crap on Netflix I
don't know why you know but I want to
say something
about you know the land and the trauma
and the fact that what happened before
we're still dealing with today in ways
that we don't even understand and um you
know again just you know trying to write
something that's kind of surprising in
the fact that I'm actually dealing with
something that's really
important
so we talked a little bit about this in
the car but um there's a framework of
matal
can you hear me now oh yeah um there's a
framework on quality maternal and
newborn care that's based on evidence
that was uh produced 10 years ago on um
uh particularly around Midwifery and it
and it has five components that look at
how we
practice um who practices who the
workers are how the practices based in
values and um
philosophy and how it's organized can
women get to it can make is it
acceptable to them so those um pretty
well make up all the things that all
women and newborn should have so if you
had one
area to invest in that you think would
make the most
impact what would you invest
in I'm laughing because she asked me
this question earlier not quite like
that and I said and my she was like if
there's one thing I could have what
would it be and I said Jeff Bezos
money uh and so now now she's like okay
so if you had Jeff Bezos money what
would be the one thing that you would
invest
in um you know I I the reason why it's
hard for me to answer it like that is
because this is a multi-pronged problem
and so you need a multi-pronged approach
that is to me the Crux of the problem
everyone keeps trying to go to one thing
like if I just go to the community and I
do this then the problem will be solved
and that's why I resist answering it
like that and I say I need a lot of
money so that I can put money towards
Pol politics so that we can affect
policy we can elect good people into
office that who are going to put forth
the kind of policies like post making
sure that all women get postpartum care
uh that is covered um that we can make
sure that all women can get Midwifery
care what I would do is I would I would
try to help the midwives get their act
together um I love midwives I I don't
mean that in a pejorative I think
midwives are amazing but what I mean by
that is really help build you know a
truly robust
Midwifery program in the United States I
mean the fact that we're the
only country the only industrialized
country that does not have Midwifery
care integrated into our Health Care
system is insane to me and so I would
really try to figure out how to do that
how to I mean I would I would invest in
at HBCU getting Midwifery programs
started and going going even younger
talk you know programs that get young
people thinking about Midwifery programs
um invest in in more birthing centers
again state by state so I got to deal
with the politics to get that happening
um but I do think that Midwifery care is
a huge answer uh and I think uh that
helping to fund them and bring them
together and set them up for Success
would be would be a huge huge in this
country sorry I'm have my bird here
because I'm a little nervous this
is thank you for being here and letting
us yeah just be with you here um if you
feel comfortable speaking personally
what was the impact of making this film
on on you and as you hold all that was
in that film I
just like and what how do you find the
strength to kind of keep moving forward
with this work I mean you've been doing
it a while and to just keep
going yeah I I have to say that shaie
Omari and Bruce are amazing human beings
um
who lost and
picked up and UHC I look at I I look at
them obviously never having met shamani
or Amber and I can see what loving loved
on beautiful Spirits these women
were and I see that because their
families hold them up on the work that
they do and you know I say that um you
know if shaie can get up
and do the work I certainly can't be
laying on the floor crying about it I
need to get up and and help support her
and uh any way that I any way that I can
um and
so the impact on me I mean it is hard
you know I hadn't seen I just saw the
film again uh last week after having not
seen it for a while and
um you know it's hard but then I look at
a Mari and I look at shaie and I look at
Bruce today I mean we met them so early
in their grief first of all they look
different right grief is
physical uh and so they they they they
look different they're doing amazing
work um the children are
thriving uh and so honestly I feel
somewhat empowered there were times
though I no no I mean it was hard I mean
you know there are other people that we
talk and you know I try to be so
professional I will say like you you
really do steal yourself right like I'm
going to be a professional I'm not going
to show emotion um but I remember
talking to some mother another father
and him explaining the death of his wife
and just I felt so bad because I just
broke I broke down and he's there saying
to me it's okay and I'm like no it's not
your job to comfort me it's my job to
comfort you you know um but and also um
you know when I look at people like
Helena Grant who was the Midwife in the
film who gave us a lot of
information um and Neil Shaw and I look
at the history that that we've been
through um I will say I'm just grateful
honestly I'm just really grateful and I
know it was a blessing I know this was a
blessing I was where I was supposed to
be in the right place at the right time
to do the work um and I'm I'm sit back
now and I'm like oh my God I can't
believe we did that it feels so easy now
that you're out of it but it was hard it
was really really hard in a lot of ways
uh and doing it I I worked out I kept
myself working out I kept myself eating
really well uh I kept boundaries with
the team uh so that we could do the work
and not get completely overtaken by it
because it is it is tough hard
stuff
[Applause]
one uh students at Young School of
Nursing questions
my question is with the after bath of
the film um since it did take place in
New York City which has such a high
disparity um between black and white
mothers or birthing persons did any
politicians or any um Community workers
did anyone reach out to you about
legislative change after watching the
film I really appreciate that question
in fact
yesterday uh I just had a debriefing uh
with uh a few Deputy mayors the
Department of Health uh a lot of uh
people in New York and um a couple of
months ago I met with two of the Deputy
Mayors uh well the deputy mayor and
another deputy mayor two black women who
sat down with me and said we want our
Legacy to be that we've improved the
outcomes or at least put things in place
to improve outcomes so it is coming I
think this morning I think or last
night
there was an oops there was just
announced like a healthy healthy New
York and within that there is um uh a
cutout for maternal health and so yes
they have reached out uh they do know
how bad it is and I think especially
these black women Deputy
Mayors want to leave office whenever
that may be knowing they've done what
they can for black and brown women in
New New York
City I good afternoon panel I'm also a
student in the DMP program and of course
I've shared with you before that I've
shown your film a number of times I
think what's important um that I wanted
to piggy back on that you said earlier
was the fact that the issues as far as
things being preventable the maternal
health issues being preventable is like
right here in Connecticut too as the
program director of maternal health
there's a maternal mortality Review
Committee right here in Connecticut that
says 80% of the deaths that occur could
have been prevented so I just wanted to
bring it on home so that it's not a
matter of looking from just a national
lens of where we are with these
statistics and these numbers but knowing
that this is hitting really close to
home in a really in a way that we can
improve on thank you for that and and
you're right I mean 80% are preventable
and then you know the other thing that
that I often don't talk about when I
just mentioned is the near- deaths you
know how many women nearly die from
child birth complications that's not
even caught in that
number hello my name is Jenny Rebecca
I'm a nurse mree student here
brooklynite um Brooklyn's in the
house before I came here I was a Dua for
about six years and the first birth I
went to I was I realized I want to see a
midwife so I went back to school did
nursing and it's interesting because
this film it was hard for me to watch it
would took four or five goes because
these were the people I worked with the
black women in New York were the ones
that would come to me and the Doula was
the answer and then as like Tom went on
um the doer was the Band-Aid and then
the Midwife was the Band-Aid for this
problem and working with a black woman I
did who you know had doctor from Harvard
and you know had three like degrees and
we're making like this much money and
they would always tell me like am I like
they would say that to their provider in
front of me and it's like that's that's
not enough it doesn't matter and to have
been on that side as a du and an
advocate was hard because you watch just
like all those sly little things that do
happen and how people do like fall
through the cracks and then becoming a
nurse I was more aware and I understood
how the systems work and now being here
having the education that I do like I'm
well aware that we are oppressed when we
are on labor and birth floors and I
don't want to be one of the providers
that doesn't listen and I truly do
believe that we have to like dismantle
these systems like the way hospitals
work the way Health Care like like
insurance is like the bane of all of
like how we have these problems like
Medicare gets cut cut off like Medicaid
gets cut off as soon as post for
postpartum and it's
like one of the reasons I came here is
because I knew that we have to change
education and like I think before my
last breath I want to like change the
way we're taught about maternal
mortality and how we're taught about
obstetric care in textbooks and I guess
like when I look at films like this um
you know I want the people that are
making decisions for care and do these
like you know ethic and bias workshops
in their hospitals to actually really
understand like it's the smallest little
moment to stop and not have 35 patients
on your roster and say can I stop for
this one person to listen that shortness
of breath or the pain in their chest or
the pain in their arm that doesn't quite
line up with PR clamps and maybe that's
what it is and to like not worry about
what things cost to send someone in for
a workup and it's like it's frustrating
now I see every single side of this
problem and then the weathering and then
systemic racism and this going back over
200 years and yeah I maybe it's just an
echo of what everyone's has said so far
but being on the side it's like you
really realize the importance and it's
the word that you use to steal yourself
like that's the only way to like that
I'm getting through this to figure out
like how can I be effective without
being um on the floor crying yeah thank
you for that you know as I listen to you
talk I think about I know you I know you
all know Jenny Joseph um I've I've had
the opportunity to be with her and hear
her speak and one of the things you know
I so appreciate about her is she's so
blunt and direct and she's like I'm
tired of talking about the problem now I
need to build a system outside of the
system like like that is what she's
thinking and like it's like how do we do
that like that that's the thing right
again you know you you think about that
right okay we're going to build it
outside of the system so women don't
have to deal but then in places like
Alabama where the outcomes in hospitals
were terrible and The Midwives and the
community said you know what we're going
to build outside of the community we're
going to build outside of the system
we're going to set up our own Midwifery
practice black women are like great
we're going to come there and then the
state comes and gets in their business
and says oh no you can't do that we want
you all to go to hospitals but our
outcomes are better so you say you want
to protect women but you're going to
send us back into the hospital where the
comes are worse so what are you really
oh you're
policing women is what what you're doing
you don't want us to figure it out so
it's I mean it is it's hard it's really
hard and really frustrating um which is
again why I need Jeff Bezos money so I
can help get better politicians in
Alabama so I can support those women who
are setting up their birthing
centers
good evening my name is SM I'm part of
the ysn faculty here at the school of
nursing and I had bear with me I'm going
to try to do this without getting
emotional um I had my first maternal um
experience three months ago when I gave
birth to at 24 weeks to a micro prey um
my daughter her name is Marissa she's
still at yel no Haven Hospital neonatal
Intensive Care Unit and when I think
about how infant mortality is deeply
rooted in systemic and structural racism
I know when I understand that I have a
black baby that's being taken care of by
a predominantly white healthc care team
and I have lost sleep over that because
she cannot talk she cannot advocate for
herself and it's something that I worry
about every single day now don't get me
wrong the team has been amazing all the
nurses and and doctors um I've you know
had a good experience so far um but it's
something that it it's it's statistics
and it's it's the facts that I'm there
every day at her bedside triy to have a
voice and Advocate I'm there they know
me by my first name I'm always there
when they're rounding on her talking
about her medical care um but it it it's
something that's like it's my life right
now being her voice being there speaking
up asking questions
um and you know giving birth was just
one part of it it it now translates to
making sure she you know she has
complications of course being born at 24
weeks but you know just being there and
making sure like are we doing the right
things and just being involved in her
care so you know I think it yes the
diversity is so important that we are
starting at diversifying the healthc
care force and having more diverse
midwives and starting with admissions
committee and you know enrolling more um
healthcare workers of you know more
diverse backgrounds and how important
that is to see you know nurses and
doctors who are of color that can relate
to our lived experiences and it's just
so important because we are taking care
of patients and this is the community
and this is the population that deserve
to have you know people that look like
go God bless you God bless
Marissa and how are you doing you're
doing okay because I know I I know we're
worried about Marissa but you know you
got to be okay too
right
and
I I understand how you feel that's a
scary thing leaving your child with
strangers who don't look like you and
yet here you are you're are you're a
nursing student so so you know the
things to say the language to use to let
them know that you know right imagine
and and and that's a blessing and it's
still scary imagine you didn't have that
you're coming from a totally different
place and you can't even talk the talk
which again you being able to talk the
talk you you hope that helps helps them
help you better no one should have to go
through that like like this is this this
is the part that makes me crazy you know
um but I really appreciate you sharing
that um and and I wish you and Marissa
all the best and um you know I wish you
the best in in in your career as well as
you go
forward oh well I I pity those nurses if
they don't get it
right that's why I said they know me by
my first name
anyone
else don't be
shy so I would like to thank you very
much for your thought-provoking uh you
know experience that you shared with us
and and also thank you all of you for
your very good questions I I I just want
to you know reiterate what you all you
know alluded to and I think that we need
to really pause and thinking about what
you said you know um that mortality rate
infant mortality mortality rate and
maternal mortality rates are raising in
this country that you know they are
rising in this country and they are
preventable and another thing that I
wanted to add to it that is that makes
it even
more outrageous is is that us spent
almost five times more in healthcare
services than any other you know High
income count so it's it's not only about
you know how much money do we use in in
to provide healthcare services and the
problem is that those um you know High
rates are not seen in the white
population so that means that there is
nothing else that is you know causing
this problem than racism nothing else
and we need to call it out and we need
to talk about it and and we need to act
on it because I think that that is I I
cannot you know it's outrageous for me
to just as a healthcare provider and
Healthcare educator to just see that
happening year out and year in and we
cannot you know that not only that we
cannot stop it but it's it's you know
increasing constantly and that is so
important for our next generation of
healthare providers here Our Midwives
and and other you know nurses that we
are H graduating that really we need to
become The Advocate and we need to do
something about be being the voice of
our our our you know the people who
otherwise don't don't have voice and and
that that is just
horrific yeah I appreciate that comment
um we had a
we had a scene that that we had to take
out of the film that was a group of
midwives uh talking around a table about
their experience and one of the things
and they are they work in hospital and
uh a couple of them were saying one in
particular said they think of themselves
as the guardian at the gate as being
midwives in the hospital system so that
when they
see behaviors that are are a racist or
traumatic to a patient they will go and
try to correct that behavior um I I
think you're 100% right we have to call
it out um you know the problem is that
those of us in this room we may you know
we we and I believe an anti-racist work
and I and I but there are moments when
it's very hard for me I get very cynical
because I you know as this country seems
to be moving in I don't know what this
crazy direction we're moving in people
don't seem to really care they don't
care about black people straight up they
just don't care about black people um
and so I try to think of it like and I
often will say well even if you don't
care about black people you should care
about this issue because it's coming for
you you know if you fix it early like in
the like the like drug crisis if in the
80s instead of vilifying people because
they had crack addictions and calling
them crackheads and locking them up and
you know Trea treating them poorly maybe
by the time we got to this opiate
situation we would be a little better
prepared to deal with it you know but
people don't learn and again white
supremacy is a very white
supremacy uh our paternalistic
society they are very powerful and
people are not trying to give it up you
know but to your point we do have to
call it out and we do have to fight as
much as we can um and we have to be
slick
and we have to call out people like
Edward Bloom and we have to figure out
how we go up against him and his cohorts
as
well thank you so much for the film and
for doing this today um I I'm curious um
the process of getting to Midwifery and
in particular birth center and
community- based Midwifery as such a
theme in this and whether that came out
of like Bruce and Amber's story because
they had sought that out or if it was
sort of in your mind to begin with
because that's you know the world that
I'm in and I can see it very clearly
that a big part of the solution to this
is community based care and Community
birth but the reality is that's a very
white world and that's not what you know
black people are accessing or even
necessarily trying to access in a lot of
parts of the country and so you know
when when I advocate for you know
Community birth as part of the solution
to Health Equity I often hear like you
know well that's not necessarily true or
how do you know or whatever so I guess
I'm just asking you how did you know and
how did that become such a such a theme
in in the film yeah I I don't know I
feel like the the black folks in uh that
I came across really do advocate for
that kind of community birthing uh for
us you're right uh with Bruce uh and
Amber was a midwife who saw that her
platelets were dropping who sent her her
to actually to the hospital for care
when she realized she couldn't care for
her um we also went down to Tulsa
Oklahoma as you saw um with Neil Shaw
and met up with the Tulsa birth Equity
initiative uh which is providing Dua
care down there um uh also separately we
we had heard about Helena Grant doing
amazing work uh at Woodhall Hospital
as the head of the Midwifery program
there and so you know I think just you
know getting into the world you know we
were just hearing lots of different
things that were going on um and I think
you know I do think that there I mean
shamani had a midwife at one point she
did uh and so we were hearing about
midwives uh talking to people about um
you know I think we know this we got to
save ourselves and so the community is
trying to figure it out uh and
everyone's talking uh and then when we
went down to Tulsa I mean that was just
you know meeting the people at Tulsa
birth Equity
initiative um a dual program down there
that connected us with Felicia who's the
woman that gave birth in the film who
really thought she was going to give
birth for with a doctor we we and she
just decided at the last minute to do
something else um those women actually
the the the um
the head of that birthing center
actually is
indigenous uh and so you know the
community is really trying to do the
work to protect themselves and come up
with with solutions to themselves and I
think that's how that's how we found
them oh and I do want to say too Neil
Shaw to his credit the doctor in the
film from Harvard also has worked works
a lot with midwives um and so and I and
I appreciate him and I I do want to
shout him out for this because as a
obstetrician gynecologist he really is
an advocate for Midwifery care and I
think that's really important because
having um having doctors who understand
the role that midwives play um I think
is really critical understanding that
it's not that everybody can work
together um is really critical and and
Neil was really is really fantastic in
that
way any other
questions
sure
and your work is contributing so much to
informing the public and us about where
we need to go what we need to do so
thank you for being here apprciate it
well thank you for having me and and
this is how we do it right like we come
together we have these conversations I
know I feel full from this conversation
from all the work that you all are doing
and as I said I take it with me and I
and I hope we all leave here and keep
having conversations with each other
with other people I will say the one
thing you know that I think is so
important and we've touched on
here is a cultural shift in how we think
about birthing in this country birth is
a sacred process it is a natural process
no one is sick it is an amazing process
and when you birth a
baby and you go through that labor as
Felicia says in the film it's the
hardest thing she's ever done she knows
she can do anything and that's why we're
so oppressed in it because if women
really if if if we're able to realize
our full power for those of us who
choose to give birth oh my God these men
wouldn't know wouldn't know what to do
with us so they're trying to keep us
tamped down uh but I think I think we
all need to think about and and I know
I'm talking I'm preaching to the choir
here but like how we talk about birth I
mean as you see I don't use the word
delivery I I no one delivered no doctors
delivered a baby women do the work they
birth a baby a baby is birthed here um
and I think if we can think about
birthing as and again it's all about
choice if I choose to give birth how I
choose to give birth where I choose to
give birth a woman has a choice in all
these things who I choose ches to birth
with when when you start getting that
kind of language um
around when we start talking to young
people about you know and and we should
talk to young people about birthing like
I don't know why it's such a mystery all
the time it's an amazing
process uh we all had to go through it
to get here and we've been doing it
since the times of ancient it's it's
it's it's amazing so I think I'll just
end with saying like I just my hope is
that and not necessarily this project
that I mentioned before but as we go on
that we really think about birthing as
the
amazing sacred awesome thing that those
of us CH who choose to do it can do it
um and hopefully that that helps people
change the way we do it as
[Music]
[Applause]
well I would like to once again thank
you very much for
uh your activism and everything that you
do to be the voice of of voiceless and
and thank you very much for uh coming
here and I uh uh can talk about you know
speak for everyone here that I think
that this was really you know uh Pro
thought provoking and and I know that we
are living here with a lot of thoughts
in our uh you know mind to continue this
work it is very important thank you so
much
thank you so much thank
[Music]
you